merci on m'a donné trois quatre minutes
pour parler j'ai dû réécrire ses 3 corse
et 3g j'ai dû réécrire mon intervention
en urgence avec un style ou qui ne
marche pas donc je vais je vais tenter
d'être le plus synthétique possible on
m'a demandé de un petit peu d'identifier
des possibilités de modernisation des
forces de sécurité en france en
s'appuyant sur des exemples étrangers et
ayant travaillé sur notamment sur les
exemples anglais britannique
c'est un peu le cahier des charges qui
m'a été confiée lors de cette de cette
matinée j'ai identifié trois chantiers
de modernisation en fait une
modernisation organisationnel une
modernisation opérationnelle et une
modernisation par non démocratique sur
la modernisation organisationnel on en a
parlé lors la première table-ronde donc
je vais être très très synthétique c'est
encore une fois par rapport à cette idée
de recentrage de la police et de la
gendarmerie sur l'émission sur ses
missions centrales
je raconte toujours une anecdote il ya
quelques mois je me suis vu confier avec
une équipe de chercheurs un travail par
la direction des ressources et des
compétences de la police sur la
formation des policiers pour ce faire on
m'a fait faire un badge d'accès sur les
sites de la police pour faire réaliser
ce badge d'accès je suis allée place
beauvau donc il ya une personne qui a
pris ma photo à imprimer la carte
d'accès cette personne était un gardien
de la paix c'était une femme gardien de
la paix qu'on utilisait en fait pour
faire une mission que n'importe quel
personnel administratif pourra effectuer
et je me suis penché sur un chiffre j'ai
voulu comparer avec la grande bretagne
un fort de cette de cette expérience
qu'est ce que j'ai vu j'ai vu qu'en
france on à 22000 si on additionne
police gendarmerie on à 22000 personnel
administratif au total en grande
bretagne il y en a trois fois plus
ils ont 66000 66000 personnel
administratif qui font l'accueil qui
font la réception d'appels alors on a
même confié au privé le transfert des
détenus
je pense que là on a un énorme levier
d'économies et de réorientation de la
police sur ses missions sur ses missions
centrales j'en viens maintenant à ce qui
peut être un petit peu plus le coeur de
cette de cette table ronde et de mon
intervention
c'est la modernisation opérationnel on a
un petit peu parlé d' outils
technologiques et
sans en faire un totem sans les
idéaliser ils peuvent être vraiment
quelque chose d'intéressant pour
identifier les problèmes je cite une
étude américaine de la fin des années 80
je vais pas transformer ceci en cours
universitaires mais en utilisant la
cartographie criminelle en utilisant en
fait une géo kg aux localisations pardon
très précise des événements et en
utilisant également une situation dans
le temps une datation très précise des
événements on s'appelle on s'est aperçu
en fait que 50 % des infractions ont été
commises sur 3 % des adresses c'était à
minneapolis
à la fin des années 80 à partir de ça on
a construit toute une doctrine qui
s'appellera dispose policing qui est en
fait le ciblage des points chauds et
après tout un tas tout un tas d'études
quand on cible les lieux les plus
problématiques anges du lieu c'est pas
un quartier c'est pas une ville c'est un
carrefour c'est un parc c'est un
immeuble qu on ya fait que des
ressources d'investigation de patrouille
qu'on y met en place des mesures
globales en partenariat avec d'autres
acteurs ont fait baisser la délinquance
exemple kansas city
il ya un endroit très précis où il y
avait le problème d'armes à feu deux
fusillades et usage répété d'armes à feu
en quatre mois
en appliquant une politique très sévère
en fait contre c'est contre ces actes là
on a fait baisser de 40 9% 4 - les
délits liés à l' usage à l'usagé des
armes à feu autre outil prometteur à
partir de la géolocalisation et
et de la localisation spatio temporelle
des infractions c'est ce qui s'appelle
le predictive policing alors je les ai
vus dans votre dans le document qui a
été diffusée ce matin dans le document
programmatique c'est quelque chose qui a
été mise en place à la salle je les sais
qu'on est allé plus loin
non seulement alors ce ne sont plus les
humains en fait qui identifie les
problèmes à partir de données
cartographiques c'est un algorithme en
fait qui va tenter de prédire
l'évolution future de la délinquance et
les déplacements de problème là-dessus
on a on en est à la phase
d'expérimentation on est sur quelque
chose qui ne qui en est à ses
balbutiements mais les premières études
menées dans cette ville montrent des
résultats qui sont plutôt prometteurs
troisième révolution a mené aux
modernisations à mener c'est la
modernisation démocratique il faut
jamais oublier le citoyen tout ce dont
on parle depuis ce matin tu en parles de
sécurité de lutte contre la délinquance
d'amélioration des conditions de travail
des policiers
à la fin au bout de la chaîne ce qu'on
recherche c'est l'amélioration de la vie
du citoyen et là il ya deux choses qui
peuvent nous nous aider à faire les
technologies première on sait déjà c'est
d'être transparent d'informer le citoyen
en grande bretagne vous tapez police
point uk vous tapez votre code postal
vous pourrez voir rue par rue
heure par heure les événements qui se
produisent à côté de chez vous on en est
très très loin en france et je trouve
personnellement anormal que le citoyen
ne sache pas ne soit pas en mesure de
savoir exactement ce qui se passe autour
de lui deuxième utilité donc ça sert à
informer la ces et le citoyen mais ça
sert aussi pour le citoyen informé
l'autorité publique applications
portables actuellement expérimenté chez
les britanniques
vous vous sentez en insécurité vous êtes
dans la rue vous êtes exposés à des
faits qui disent on ne vous rassure pas
un rassemblement quelqu'un qui vous à
menacer quelqu'un qui vous avez insultés
vous pouvez directement le signaler sur
votre téléphone portable
qu'est ce que ça apporte ça apporte non
seulement une cartographie de la
criminalité qui est fournie par les
données que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
ça fournit également une cartographie du
sentiment d'insécurité
ce qui est extrêmement important pour là
aussi affecté au mieux les ressources
policières pour conclure je ne sais pas
si j'ai tenu le défi des trois minutes
j'espère ne pas en être très loin
le message qu'il faut aussi retenir de
tout ça c'est qu'il faut pas hésiter à
expérimenter et à évaluer ce qu'on fait
créer des zones pilotes lancés des
choses novatrices sur des territoires
restreints quitte à les étendre ensuite
moi j'ai été assez frappé il ya quelques
semaines j'ai été j'ai été invité à la
radio pour commenter la généralisation
des caméras portatives sur les policiers
ça a été évoqué un instant par monsieur
le douaron et on m'a dit mais alors il
parait ça marche il paraît que ça marche
très bien
jeudi apparemment ça marche très bien
moi je suis totalement favorable à cette
mesure
simplement la communication du
gouvernement autour de ça c'est de dire
on a des remontées très positif du
terrain mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire
c'est qu'on n'a pas de dispositifs réels
d'évaluation est-ce qu'on a moins
d'outragé de rébellion à cause de ça est
ce qu'on a moins de violence à l'égard
des policiers est allé à linverse les
violences policières diminue en gros on
n'a pas mis en place parallèlement à
cette innovation un véritable dispositif
de contrôle d'évaluation scientifique de
l'efficacité
voilà merci